hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 18 2016 what's going on how
are you I hope you're good I hope things
are well and everything okay with you
and the family anyways this is the last
week of writing for emphasis or family
you know we've got a table read today
and then tomorrow we punch up you know
fix whatever jokes didn't work at the
table read and then on Wednesday we
record it and then I get my wife back so
[ __ ] excited so [ __ ] excited to
have this behind me all these friggin
work and I'm very excited for you guys
to see this thing granted it's animation
so it'll come out sometime [ __ ] 2036
or something I don't know that's how it
works that's that's how the process
works but I know the big thing is
actually writing the scripts and we're
finishing it tomorrow after the punch up
and then I'm done I literally I have the
same giddiness I used to have remember
like the second week of June with just
even the [ __ ] Nerds didn't give a
[ __ ] anymore right they weren't cleaning
their glasses they were just showing up
they didn't give a [ __ ] right
it teaches with dressing casual everyone
just was yeah it's over it's over let's
get the [ __ ] out of here you know it's
unbelievable I don't you know that's why
like sometimes when I look at homeless
people because everybody just wants to
get the [ __ ] out and nobody you know you
still want to work every once in a while
you look at like these [ __ ] bums and
I don't mean like people like try
something tragic happen to him
you don't I mean like I don't know like
some sinkhole swallowed up their [ __ ]
home and then they didn't have sinkhole
insurance and now they're [ __ ] you
know sleeping at a bus station I don't
mean those people I mean the bumps the
old school hobos the guys out there
riding the [ __ ] railroads right let's
stick with a handkerchief around it with
a little peanut butter and fluff another
sandwich inside of it those guys go they
got a
they always feel how I feel right now
you know why because they never have to
go to work it's always over it's always
over and then you know what do you do
you go to a new town you wash some
dishes next thing you know you know
you're eating beans over a fire outside
you know even with a knife or some [ __ ]
you know does that one other used to do
it is that just what the actors used to
do in those old movies trying to make an
interesting choice how many with my
knife maybe that'll make me the next
John Wayne um yeah they have it [ __ ]
figured out you never done that you have
a walk down the street in the middle of
day the middle of your [ __ ] stressful
day you're coming back from lunch
wondering mentally how the [ __ ] am I
going to get through the next four four
and a half [ __ ] hours he is walked by
and you see some homeless guy just
[ __ ] just napping laying on a park
bench or even on the sidewalk and she's
so [ __ ] sprawled out and just in such
a deep level of sleep it actually looks
appealing for half a second you know
that's what the interview one of those
people just be like won the Superbowl
this year just to see how out of the
loop they are slash how big are sports
you know do you know who Tiger Woods is
do you know what happened to you know
are you aware that we're at war right
now still where were you when it started
were you behind a desk were you normal
you know do you have a suit did you sit
there and laugh at jokes that you didn't
think we're funny but just doing it to
try to get to the next level [ __ ]
cubicle is that what you did at what
point did you just decide [ __ ] this I
want to take a nap when I want to nap
can you imagine if you were allowed to
nap whenever you wanted to nap how much
better the world would be you could just
be at work and just be like you know I
gotta go lay down for about [ __ ] 20
minutes just go over and curl up in a
[ __ ] ball and that'll be it you know
what I'm trying to say people is I'm
very excited as much
as I enjoy writing these [ __ ] things
it's just great data you know i'm look
at my dog right now just [ __ ]
chilling out just [ __ ] laying that
she's laying there she I don't even know
why she's tired [ __ ] tired from all
you goddamn sleep and I'm jealousy you
Cleo
Claire nothing she knows I'm talking
about it but she doesn't give a [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] tapped out she's laying on
the rug there's a little bit of Sun
spilling in from the window and she
picked the sunny warm part of the rug
and that is it that's all the [ __ ] she
needs you know no upward mobility she's
not working on her next [ __ ] season
of you know [ __ ] the real pit bulls
of the Greater Los Angeles area she
doesn't give a [ __ ] she's got nothing on
her agenda every day it's [ __ ]
tremendous maybe that's why their lives
are only 10 to 15 years you know they
just get to live like all you know
because when you look at your whole life
if you're lucky you get 10 to 15 years
total of just bliss and the rest of it
you know it was just dealing with some
[ __ ] with coffee breath telling you you
didn't have enough you didn't bring the
right [ __ ] forms you got to go back
home and go get something else and span
the line again that's that's what the
rest of your life is like but if you're
lucky 10 to 15 [ __ ] years of it you
know you get to live like my dog right
now taking a nap on the sunny part of
the rug by the way there's so much [ __ ]
going on right now like on the internet
on the interweb that I just understand
what is the big [ __ ] deal you know
that hope George Bush dancing thing I
looked that up thinking he was going to
be just an absolute [ __ ] lunatic like
oh now stop stop you making all white
dudes look bad everybody already knows
we can't dance
it wasn't bad at all you look like he
was in a good mood you know I his
[ __ ] energy that's like I get that
[ __ ] energy he's he's showing up
he's a patriotic son of a [ __ ] that's
his jam you know he sways a little bit
and you know what's great too is in his
head he's laughing at Obama like go on
aha you still have to do that job George
Bush is on summer vacation
and the [ __ ] look he has on his face
that's the same look I have all I got to
get through I just got to get through
[ __ ] basically tomorrow get through
the next rewrite and then that's it and
of course you know there'll be a zillion
punch ups and editing sessions but like
the [ __ ] daily grind is it's done
that's where George Bush is at right now
you know he [ __ ] launched the
missiles all right once your [ __ ]
people died he's mentally passed it he
bought his pieces of land down in South
America that sit on aquifers you know
who knows maybe he goes out he gets a
[ __ ] 12-pack I don't he just looked
like a really [ __ ] happy guy since
when does a president have to know how
to [ __ ] dance he does it all his
[ __ ] job is to get on TV and scare
the [ __ ] out scare the [ __ ] out of you
about whatever the [ __ ] people above
them who want to make money on something
you know we got to get these people we
got to get those people we got to get
some people there's some people out
there to come and get you coming to get
you these people Manny's people they
don't like you they don't like you
sitting there on your couch it's like
how the [ __ ] do they not like me they
don't even know me I haven't interacted
with these [ __ ] you know who has you
have there what did you with your
friends do to piss them off
you know what I mean you went out and
you pissed off another [ __ ] country
now you're trying to make it seem like
they're out again and I coming after me
- coming after you you can't they're
never going to get to you you know why
because you have security and I don't
I'm just [ __ ] sitting here sitting
here with a mug of [ __ ] teeth that
would be great collectively if the world
did that you know in the world leaders
right all of them they wanted to start a
war and be like any people and those who
are the people don't [ __ ] you know
didn't Fidel's and all anybody dis all
regular people just said I really
thought what's going on well listen dude
if you got a beef with them why don't
you go [ __ ] settle it because I've
never talked to those people and then
that's it then we watch it on
pay-per-view
you know slap fights world leaders slap
fights
you know and it doesn't solve anything
other than we just get to enjoy complete
[ __ ] sociopathic money power-hungry
[ __ ] psychos just slap at each other
in the face you know didn't we just get
to sit in a crowd eatin popcorn going ah
just watch them slapping each other
that's just funny you know something if
we were really civilized that's as far
as it would go you know we just sit
there watch you know Obama have a slap
fight with the al Qaeda guy or a [ __ ]
Isis guy and then that would be it and
there'd be nobody underneath any of them
would even be Obama it would be the
[ __ ] the corporate [ __ ] who make all
the [ __ ] money off the misery I'm
sorry people just that that yeah I hate
how they always act like the world is
going crazy the world is not going crazy
you just keep showing the crazy [ __ ]
it's like these [ __ ] lunatics that
can't they drove the [ __ ] truck into
the people it's like why did that guy do
that people never did [ __ ] like that at
least to the city when I was growing up
people did not do [ __ ] like that at
least as far as the sheer amount of
these [ __ ] incidents now and I really
think it's because I think it's the news
coverage they wanted their last act on
earth they want people to then be like
inside the crazy mind of Jill blow he
was born in it they get to do his whole
[ __ ] backstory I think that that's
what they're going for so obviously when
something like that happens you got a
report on it but I don't think I don't
want to know the person's name I don't
know a [ __ ] thing but they should die
completely [ __ ] anonymous and I think
if they maybe why don't we try that you
know instead of you know the people who
get [ __ ] killed maybe they talk about
it for [ __ ] you know once or whatever
but the person who [ __ ] kills
everybody you know they get their own
little [ __ ] half-hour hour-long
special you know as news people sit
there with their brow furrowed you know
disturbing just starving normal Bubble
Bobble and they can [ __ ]
talk about it for 24 hours in the
million dollars in advertising oh I'm a
[ __ ] cynical canta dick absolutely
but by the way that Bush dancing thing
was that was not bad at all he looked
like he was he was in a great mood and
you know what's good for him good for
him that [ __ ] dope
guy say he's a dope I can't really say
he's a dope a guy you guys bilingual
right you got to have some sort of
brains in there I'm smart enough to
realize he didn't belong at Yale so he
[ __ ] drowned it in a 12-pack every 20
minutes I mean I relate to the guy
anyways oh by the way if one more person
[ __ ] tweets me about that stupid
suspension the Tom Brady think this
sheer amount of people that don't even
understand that had that has nothing to
do you know like all of a sudden it was
proven that you see he is a cheat cheat
cheater did not that's not what if that
was about the first one that was the did
he cheat and that went to a court of law
and was laughed out of court the second
one all that was was the NFL they
changed their argument they go where a
corporation he's our employee do we have
the right to suspend him and the court
was like yes you do and then they came
back and they said hey Tom remember that
[ __ ] trial we had with no [ __ ]
evidence whatsoever the kind of evidence
that gets laughed out of court well
we're going to uphold it so you're
suspended so that's basically what
happens I just don't people hear what
the [ __ ] they want to hear all right all
freckles has been working out all
freckles he's been working out I would
told you I was up to 186 and [ __ ]
change stepped on the scale this week
182 and change telling the first week
you can always drop three to four
because it's such a shock to your system
of like holy [ __ ] with doing this now if
you just start eating healthy working
out right
stop eating around five or six o'clock
and just crush waters and you don't eat
again till 8:00 the next morning you
know I'm telling you if you can drop
three to four now
now I'm in my second week of this [ __ ]
so I want to get down to 179 and then
the week after that 176 so I'm in the
mid-17th herb so I represent my [ __ ]
country properly okay all those European
contact for you know who doesn't know
what's going on in the world that's what
they want so what you do is is you show
up in shape right you go on Wikipedia
you google their [ __ ] city right you
find out what's going on and then you
just pretend you read you sit there with
your flat stomach and you pretend like
you read that's what you do and you know
what it irritates them I'm [ __ ] with
you anyway so I'm down to 182 and 179
next week the big seven I got to see
that man that second numbers got to be a
seven it can't I refuse to be an 8 or
higher
ever I just can't [ __ ] do it although
having said that at my age how slow my
metabolism is and how much I like to
[ __ ] eat and drink and all of that
[ __ ] I could easily I get hit two bills
like if I really like just shut it all
down as far as moving around you know I
just stop doing shows and I just sat
here like my dog I swear to god dude I
could be 200 pounds by the beginning of
October easy
that's not even [ __ ] trying without
even [ __ ] trying if I just ate what
the [ __ ] I wanted to eat oh my god is
there a worse site than at [ __ ] 593
quarter 210 pound redheaded male and
that's not something that you want to
see and I don't mean muscle I just mean
coming at you looking like you know I
work at Dairy Queen and I'm constantly
taking advantage of my employee discount
nobody wants to see that right it's not
a minute looking like my legs my pasty
fat [ __ ] legs as white as the
soft-serve vanilla ice cream that I have
every 20 minutes
so anyways I'm going to get down to 179
next week
I just been [ __ ] hitting the goddamn
elliptical and do my sciatica is just
it's completely [ __ ] gone I'm going
for now I'm getting massage every
[ __ ] week right that deep tissue just
somebody beats the [ __ ] out of you and
I'm getting all of this stuff all of
these [ __ ] wall is crap that was in
my legs from all of these years flying
on planes playing pick-up hockey with no
hockey stuff you know they tell you guys
that [ __ ] no I don't think I did yeah I
had another [ __ ] massage and this
lady had her elbow jammed so far into
the back of my leg my hamstring I was
like having memories of every time I
[ __ ] up my leg she hit a spot in a bit
and then I'd be like oh yeah that was
the time I played pick-up hockey and all
I had was gloves a helmet and a stick
I was playing defense right and I'm
skating full speed you know because we
have the puck and all of a sudden they
steal it and I tried to [ __ ] turn
around to go back the other way dude and
I caught an edge who's kidding who I
suck at skating I can barely go
backwards and I [ __ ] shot up in the
air and landed on my left side ass cheek
all the way down in my thigh I landed so
hard I didn't even hit my head and I
still saw stars and that was one of
those things where I didn't even try to
get up I just sat there for a second
just waiting for everything to settle
afterwards and then [ __ ] it I got up
fast enough before everybody came over
and said dude you all right you are
right you don't to be that guy and I
just [ __ ] like you know skated over
the bench one leg working I was just
like hey hey all the way over and I just
sat down and like I you know you know
pick-up hockey people skate over they
pointed at you I shook off like three
three times and before I went back out
there and the bruise was so deep it
didn't show up for like three days
like three days later I was on the road
and I'm showering and you know I thought
I thought I saw like a bunch of grease
on the back of my leg um I put the [ __ ]
that I sit on and then I saw was a
bruise it literally looked like somebody
just took a bat and hit me right across
the back of my left leg and you know
ever this is kind of what I learned I
thought like when the bruise went away
then you will all fine but evidently
that's not the deal the reason why it
takes that long I guess for it to come
to the surface is because it's so
[ __ ] whatever you hit was so [ __ ]
deep into the muscle it took that long
for I forget the person explained it to
me a bunch of busted capillaries or
something like that and then when they
go to heal sometimes they confuse to
something else I don't know seems to a
nerve or some [ __ ] I have no idea I
don't remember I don't pretend to
remember but all I know is a bunch of
[ __ ] like that happened slash you know
flying on planes and sitting on my
[ __ ] ass and writers rooms and that's
what's going to happen but what I love
is you know all these people who have
back problems were telling me that I'll
do it you're going to have this for the
rest of your life and bla bla bla bla
bla I mean I didn't fly a helicopter for
like [ __ ] three months during this
because when I sat down my feet went
numb and I can't have my [ __ ] feet
going numb when I'm trying to touch the
pedals there but no if you find use if
you find a [ __ ] a real masseuse a
[ __ ] incredible one they could figure
out what the [ __ ] wrong with you and
even beyond a chiropractor
they beat the [ __ ] out of you and they
loosen everything up and then everything
relaxes and you go back to being normal
at least that's what the [ __ ] happened
with me and I flew for the first time
Wednesday Ostra Mendes that was
tremendous
oh Jesus Christ look at that is that
that is that a [ __ ] Raven
hey hey [ __ ] yeah yo get out of here
Jesus Christ how old am i that I had to
yell that long and a bird before it left
back in the day I stepped on a stick and
the [ __ ] thing took off what does
that mean was that a crow or a [ __ ]
Raven
all right we got to look this [ __ ] up
here some [ __ ] ancient medieval
history [ __ ] for you
Raven uh what do you say here Raven
super Raven superstition alright little
what do we got here
what do we got here Ravens symbolism
Ravens symbolism myths of the Raven
symbolisms and lore learn about the lore
of ravensberg I know that's what I'm
here for
all right the raven often has a bad
press for being a carrion carrion bird I
know what that means CA RR io n it is
ultimately associated with death
tremendous finally getting [ __ ]
healthy now I'm going to die and
consequently considered a bad omen by
many or a forewarning of war not Jesus
he is going to yell at me but there is
much more to this eggnog nematic and
intelligent bird than death darkness and
destruction Raven is a trickster a
protector a teacher and a bringer of
great magic I would love to see the
person who wrote this like what they
would dress like I just pictured them
like a [ __ ] toga with the leaves you
know the hats that have leaves on the
side it's like if you had a full head of
leaf hair and then you went bald and
just [ __ ] wrapped around you learn
all about the Raven and it's Laura here
well it's what the [ __ ] I'm here for you
[ __ ]
alright the Raven is not only the
largest member of the crow family I
didn't know that it's the big brother
but the largest perching bird in the
world I thought they all perched the
other layout an extremely intelligent
bird the raven was once extremely common
but persecution now finds it only in
remote areas such as cliffs mountains
and moon and more moons and Moors it's
amazing the amount of English words I
don't know they're more as I thought
those were Africans I just [ __ ] I
know I evidently was a crow because I
don't have any of those things
no clip there's no mountain I have a
porch
the adult is completely black with a
shaggy throw I don't care what the [ __ ]
does it mean Ravens are extremely
intelligent in some cases can even learn
to talk alright that wasn't a [ __ ]
Bravin I was just yelling at it it would
have been like that would have freaked
me out be like oh you know I was just
wondering what if you'd leave don't be
cool the wolf and the Raven are often
mentioned together in mythology lore and
scripture in nature the wolf and the
Raven have an important relationship
wolves use Ravens as an arial 'arial
spotters for possible sources of food as
well as using them to alert them of
danger ahead
the raven also gains from this
relationship with the wolf being carrion
Birds I'm so sick of reading that
[ __ ] word what does it mean CA RR io
o n you know it's funny the amount of
people that are listening just right now
and they feel superior to me because
they know what this word means yeah and
what is that getting is that going to
buy you a sandwich today the decaying
flesh of dead animals okay so that's
what it eats
alright so it's like a [ __ ] it's like
one of those birds of vulture birds with
the [ __ ] red head no [ __ ] feathers
I know why they don't have feathers on
their heads because they're always
eating a dead carcasses and they don't
want the maggots to get in there so they
do whatever [ __ ] bacteria and [ __ ]
gets on their head just gets burned off
by the Sun although I can't tell you I
look like a raven after or not a raven
if I look like a [ __ ] vulture if I go
to the beach
big [ __ ] red head you know and I eat
dead meat too right
ham sandwich that's a dead pig Jesus
Christ this is an incredible article
alright the Raven also gains from its
relation to the dead okay obviously if
the wolf [ __ ] and kill something with
Jesus Christ I don't think I can find
two more boring animals on the planet
than those two [ __ ] I think they
deserve each other they're probably both
in bed by 8:00 every night
alright let me let me do a couple of
[ __ ] reeds here we've done a lot of
advertising we didn't have any on
[ __ ] Thursday so I got to make up for
I got to make up for this [ __ ] alright
hey hey no no that's a read actually
here
I need the advertising wait a
is he advertising all right hey Billy's
grip stank ow you [ __ ] jerk-off you
did the same one twice is it really
going to be one of these days all right
hang on a second people I apologize
hang on content reads there we go
uh-oh here we go track error everybody
smart guys smart phones smart homes
technology has made everything wicked
smaht but losing your stuff makes my
people feel really stupid kid tracker
makes losing things a thing of the past
tracker it's a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bag
computers anything in seconds just pair
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything and it finds the precise
location with the tap of a button it's
that easy lose your phone press the
button on tracker and your phone rings
even when it's on silent alright it's
kind of creepy with over 1.5 million
devices tracker has the largest crowd
GPS network in the world so your lost
item shows up on a map even if it's
miles away never lose anything again
with tracker why don't I get this
[ __ ] thing I lose my phone all the
time
listen to this show to get a special
discount of 30% off your entire order go
to the track r th e TR a cker dot-com
and enter the promo code birth bu r are
the hardest thing you'll ever have to
find you'll ever have to find is their
website go to tracker calm right now and
use the promo code bar for 30% off your
entire order again high tracker calm
promo code bar oh look who's back club
Debbie Debbie homeland on an aquifer
clogged davia back to drinking booze
delivers wine straight to your door they
send you wine that is personalized to
your palate / tastes through your own
through our palate quiz their
recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate
Club Debbie I like to swing when I dance
works with top wine makers and growers
from around the world directly to make
all of their own wine you choose the
type quality of bottles with no men
Jeffie or cancellation fee and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed their $13
bottles would normally retail for 20
bucks right now Club Debbie
Al Gore couldn't beat me it's offering
listeners $20 off your first order when
you go to club w.com / / and it gets
even better I know you all hate paying
for shipping so Club Getty they don't
let me go to build a brand anymore
will actually pay for your shipping on
orders of four bottles or more so take
something off of your to-do list just go
to club Debbie comms / perk to get $20
off your first order now that's Club
Debbie and calm / / alright score big
everyone you know what you're paying too
much for tickets between all the markups
and last-minute convenience charges even
print at home it's even printed home
fees the ultimate [ __ ] / you end up
paying courtside prices for nosebleed
seats score big is here to change that
did you know that 40% of all live ticket
events go unsold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats at
huge savings
it's called score big score big works
directly with your favorite teams and
artists to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices only with score big
can you name a ticket price and be
guaranteed to pay below box office up to
60% off Jesus Christ then we can some
big claims here one go to score big calm
or download the new score big app for
your iPhone and find the event and seats
you want to make it offer why don't you
do this with the Superbowl because
evidently 40% of those tickets go unsold
and you can pay for less less than a
ticket value these guys are amazing to
make an offer what score big name and a
ticket price feature 3 get an instant
answer and save up to 60% off your
ticket for what game [ __ ] state vs.
uh soliloquy something or other for
easiest for the easiest ways to say
tickets download the new score big app
for your iPhone enter promo code birth
at the checkout and you'll save an extra
20 bucks off your first ticket purchase
no iPhone no problem get $20 off online
when you go to store
score big calm that score big calm promo
code burr hey
score big comp robocco / I'm going to
try those guys oh jesus [ __ ] christ
we got like 20 of these oh look who's
back by that face me on DS me undies
living on an aquifer would you do me
undies the undies get some for him and
her wrap up or [ __ ] or your balls then
walk into the [ __ ] waterfalls your
balls stay dry even if they're cold they
[ __ ] shrivel up oh yeah and pull into
your body so you don't freeze to death
alright whether you're wearing a suit or
sweats you spent almost 24 hours a day
in your underwear but instead of making
a statement like Superman's tights under
his everyday clothes your underwear is
probably boring me undies is here to
change that every pair of my undies is
made from sustainable source model
Modell a fabric that's twice as soft is
caught nothing can describe the fit and
the feel with me undies but once you try
them on you'll understand while they're
why they are called the world's most
comfortable underwear and if you don't
love your first pair of me undies
they're free no questions asked me
undies has dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear
whether anyone can see them or not
remember Superman shipping is free in
the United States and Canada you can
save up to $8 a pair with the me undies
subscription plan get the subscription
or a single pair get 20% off your first
order when you go to Munez comm cyber
that's been accomplished / for 20% off
your first order high the undies dot-com
/ / alright there's three left and I'm
going to read those later let's get back
to the [ __ ] podcast Here I am
sweating me
roasted bacon boy you don't actually
checked in I check in on the world of
baseball I have not looked at all my
[ __ ] Boston Red Sox if I can call on
that or a game out behind the Baltimore
Orioles and went between two dirty Birds
Orioles and Blue Jays right Yankees are
in fourth
Tampa Bay's bringing up the [ __ ]
rear here's what's interesting to me in
first place you got Cleveland all right
you got Baltimore they have not won a
World Series since 1983 you got the
Cleveland Indians they haven't won since
like [ __ ] was in 1948 or something
Texas has never won you got the
Washington Senators they're in first
place they used to be the Expos they
never won
they should have won in 94 but the
[ __ ] strikes [ __ ] cut off the
whole season the Chicago Cubs they
haven't won since 1907 and then the San
Francisco Giants who've won every other
year this decade all right look at the
[ __ ] Los Angeles Dodgers are only a
game and a half out I have no [ __ ]
clue because they're not on my cable
service because they had some [ __ ]
canta canta fight with somebody it's
just the worst so that's pretty cool man
what a great year for baseball you know
all right if I if I could see Baltimore
Cleveland or Texas I would pick
Cleveland if I could see Washington Cubs
or San Francisco you got to go with the
Cubs right now they're foofy [ __ ]
fans taking their shirts off at the
[ __ ] games they don't give a [ __ ]
right so if it was Cleveland versus the
Cubs you know I got to go with Cleveland
who just won an NBA title let's see them
get the [ __ ] you know the monkey off
their back with baseball and I would
root for the Cubs but I just don't think
the people care enough every time I see
a male total ball gay it's just too
[ __ ] happy there and I also blame
them I really feel like because they do
that stupid [ __ ] in the seventh inning
that's why the [ __ ] uh you know the
Yankees play YMCA that's why the Red Sox
play that [ __ ] horrific Sweet
Caroline the Cubs started it and because
you created that and I have to group any
time I see a Red Sox game and I have to
watch a woman put her head on the
shoulder of her boyfriend during the
seven things stretch as everybody sings
that horrific ly creepy [ __ ] song you
know I kind of hope the Cubs go another
hundred and [ __ ] six years hundred
they're up to a hundred and eight years
you know I mean not even the Phillies
went that long the biggest losers and
professionals nobody's more lost more
[ __ ] games than those [ __ ] and they
went almost on they went from like
eighteen eighty to nineteen eighty are
like eighteen eighty two to nineteen
eighty let me see Chicago Cubs Chicago
Cubs last world that comes right up 1907
I'm sorry 1908 would you look at that so
it's been a hundred and [ __ ] eight
years they should keep it going at that
point you know what I mean you just you
just be who you are right
plus the [ __ ] White Sox one one I
don't understand cities that have to
[ __ ] teams I just don't get it and
then one of the team wins it and you
don't go to the parade it's like it's it
represents your city dude how many
[ __ ] teams two unique New York City
evidently in order to remain successful
for as much [ __ ] as New York City talks
they need two football teams two
baseball teams two basketball teams and
two hockey teams [ __ ] unbelievable I
don't know if you come from a real city
like Boston you just need four and a
[ __ ] soccer team and they'll all win
championships if you know what the [ __ ]
you doing you don't have to hedge your
bets double down in every [ __ ] sport
telling you you know if it's really
making my day his Rappaport has just
been lately the guy he's just he just
won't [ __ ] leave me alone he was all
he was another little guy all excited
about the Tom Brady [ __ ] sites like
Michael I agree with the suspension a
corporation should be allowed to suspend
an employee even if it is complete
horseshit I just made a Giants fan they
[ __ ] own the Patriots in the Super
Bowl why can't he just be happy with
that you know what it is about New York
fans is when they look at Boston fans
they don't see the misery anymore you
know we can talk [ __ ] it's [ __ ] great
and they don't know how to handle it
they want us to be miserable again and
we're not
it's driving them nuts in like the
misery that Rappaport has that I'm not
miserable that's the kind of people that
these New York sports fans are that's
why they got to get all of these [ __ ]
teams they like to [ __ ] in there like
Walmart they're trying to [ __ ] you
know have so many locations they put
everybody else out of [ __ ] business
it's just it's not going to happen it's
not going to [ __ ] happen all right so
why don't you get three teams in every
sport then maybe you could run the table
in ten years you [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
Oh God who would ever thought as a
Boston sports fan I could just sit here
and laugh at New York sports fans I
never thought that that was going to
happen you know Here I am all [ __ ]
happy oh [ __ ] what am i up to 36 minutes
okay here we go here we go all right hey
let's do some reads here hey Billy
grip-strength one of your listeners
wrote in last week wrote in last week to
ask about his hairy girlfriend I'm not
sure what he ended up telling her or if
he sent you an update but unfortunately
I've had experience with this on a
couple of occasions now for those of you
who didn't listen the other day this guy
was dating this Brazilian woman you know
so you know she's [ __ ] smoking hot
but you know she just had a little issue
she had a little bit of fur or [ __ ]
arms and uh with the [ __ ] stamp would
go you know the tattoo could get lost in
the weeds if you know what I mean so he
wanted to tell her to [ __ ] wax a
little bit cuz you know kid I'm a Jesus
Christ yeah you're not doing it doggy
style she's got like a [ __ ] afro just
above a Bowie crack I mean yeah I mean
what's going on with that so but how do
you tell somebody then I mean women can
tell guys that in a second like you
should wax your back I don't know yeah
it just grosses me out and you're like
all right
that's what it takes dad you keep
[ __ ] me right you can't tell these
ladies anything you know honey I love
you to death but your back reminds me of
Gabe
Appling I had an experience with this on
a couple of occasions under no
circumstance should you ever tell her
she's Harry I was dating an Indian broad
for a while and she had excessive hair
growth on her forearms lower back feet
and toes but worst of all nose hair let
that he said imagine let that image sink
in is what you wanted to say this chick
was super cool and very attractive but
the hair situation was bothering me so I
broke up with her at her place but made
the mistake of telling her why oh god
dude why would you do that let it be
known this was a bad idea
well now dude if you just told her you
know there was a way you know obviously
if you [ __ ] listen I'm breaking up
with you I think you're a sweetheart
but physically I can't deal with all of
your hair yeah that's going to devastate
her anyways
long story short she flipped her [ __ ]
and threw plates silverware pots etc at
me while screaming and crying so I left
when I came back later for my [ __ ] she
had thrown bleach on some of my clothes
and stapled condoms to the wall you
could say things got hairy lol why do
women just get to just destroy men's
property all of the [ __ ] time you
know like if the cops show up and she's
throwing all your [ __ ] up they do hey
let's wait Conda I saw just get in the
car just just get away from her so she
calms down its destruction of property
it's like a zillion YouTube videos of
women just destroying their guy's cars I
don't understand it I really think men
should start prosecuting them for this
[ __ ] we always just go like hey dude
when she [ __ ] flipped out whatever I
can get another flat screen just get her
away from me
all in all he said if the listener
hasn't told this lady about his
displeasure of her hair I highly
recommend he doesn't well dude you
[ __ ] told her you should have just
said listen
that's the [ __ ] reason you're going
to break up with it you should not have
brought it up what did you say
yeah listen how yeah we we got to talk
um this isn't working for me
Wow yeah I'm just not happy well what is
it did I do something is it something I
said
or what's the problem you're too hairy
your hairy toes you have hair above your
ass and it's coming out of your nose and
I just you know you just reminded me of
John Matuszak and I just you know it's
turning me like why would you do that to
somebody that what you did sir was
[ __ ] me on once one part of me
actually respects the fact that you
actually communicate and even was
[ __ ] me is you're going to get what
you want in life if you if you just
don't give a [ __ ] about other people's
feelings to that level you're never
going to end up trapped in a [ __ ]
relationship so it's good that you do
that but in the future sir if you're
going to broke up break up with
something something something somebody
because of something physical you know
keep that to yourself
you know because who's kidding who dude
that's not the only reason why you broke
up but there you know if you get it
[ __ ] tell her she was too [ __ ]
hairy if you still liked her why
wouldn't you just say listen can you do
me a [ __ ] favor you got hairy toes
can we start off with that Jesus Christ
I was like updating a [ __ ] cave woman
it's 2016
have you watched any porno in your life
alright on a side note he said you
mentioned your home gym and current
workouts but I've never heard you talk
about deadlifts do you plan on doing
them and if you already do what type of
progress are you making
thanks to go flawed yourself what is a
deadlift is that the one where you
[ __ ] bend over at the waist and pull
it up or is that the one where you
[ __ ] you act like you're in the
Olympics and you lift it up over your
head both of those look like something I
shouldn't be doing at my age all right
videos deadlifts alright five common
stakes the deadlift alright here we go
oh Jesus what is this for that so that's
the one you'll blow out your back one no
if you use proper form does the lifter
have an Instagram his hip should be the
first things that move there's a lot of
vital information missing from this hips
hip wide stance hands just outside they
have full grip of the bar shoulders
slightly in front of the bar lumbar
curve maintained so at your back yeah
dude I'm going to give a big [ __ ] that
to that exercise unless you can tell me
what the hell it does to me other than
increase my chances of blowing out my
back I just got with the legs I go
hiking and I do I do bodyweight
exercises you know the same way I do
grip strength stuff I'm really into just
being able to move my [ __ ] body I
don't need to pick up a car like I'm
grabbing it by its bumper and try to use
my [ __ ] proper form but who knows
you know what I'll look those up you
know I'm sure I'm going to get a big
[ __ ] lecture on oh my good you don't
do deadlifts you might as well know be
weirder too though alright dear
bald ass Billy Gunn regarding your
caller who needs advice on getting his
girlfriend to shave off body hair okay
here we go
I would like to tell tell him to be
careful what he wishes for I had a
girlfriend with really hairy arms and
because of it she had very low
self-esteem once we got to college her
friends took her to a beauty salon and
she had her arm hair waxed shortly after
she started to receive a lot of new male
attention
and pretty soon had little time for me
shortly after she told me she needed to
talk though Regus yes she moved up in
the draft she had a good combine she
told me she didn't want to limit her
options in college good for her because
I was devastated I told her that since I
found her attractive when nobody else
did that that should count for something
she replied with we all make mistakes
and walked out Jesus
anyways consider your moves carefully
before doing something brash thanks for
the subpar podcast - go [ __ ] yourself
PS take it easy on guys writing to you
for solutions they are obviously at rock
bottom if they are willing to take
advice from a dyslexic freckled
consciousness this guy took two shots at
me um well yeah that's [ __ ] brutal
and that's once again that is something
where where it when it was going the
other way women would be like that's
brutal but then if they read this same
[ __ ] story and as much as they dumped
you she dumped you when you accepted her
for who you were they would all be like
that's right you go girl you go get what
the [ __ ] you want life dude that's kind
of [ __ ] funny
I mean does that [ __ ] with your
self-esteem at all I think it did I
think that's why you gave me [ __ ] not
once but twice at the end of it I think
you got a little bit of anger which I
would have had anger - Jesus Christ you
know what's funny about that is like she
if she keeps [ __ ] doing it and enough
time goes by the next guy who date's her
is going to have no idea that that's
part of her [ __ ] genetics and then
he's going to have a little hairy baby
and be like where the [ __ ] did this come
from since we like you know I don't know
[ __ ] baby going out looking like
Robin Williams arms remember his [ __ ]
furry arms rest his soul oh my god
that's [ __ ] everything anything
happens to a guy just it just ends up
being funny I don't know what it is
everything happens to a woman is tragic
but just when [ __ ] happens to guys it's
[ __ ] funny what are you gonna do you
know what you're going to do buddy you
go to the [ __ ] gym right you go to
the gym and just go you know just start
hitting out at kitten on [ __ ] way out of
your [ __ ] league you know do it do it
for yourself man she's
reaching for the [ __ ] stars so should
you take that as an inspiration and you
know god help the next [ __ ] guy she
gets with jesus [ __ ] christ and then
you know some the whole time she walks
this earth she has to live with that
secret you know as I tell you there's no
[ __ ] way she's telling the next guy
that that's what's going on if that held
her back right and even you know when
she walks around and hangs out with all
these other [ __ ] beautiful women now
in her beautiful people circle and they
have like [ __ ] no hair on arms
there's going to be something in the
back of her head you know and one day
she'll have too many white Zinfandels
and she'll just say to her [ __ ]
boyfriend I got to tell you well maybe
she won't maybe she won't and someday
they have the hairy baby
the OHP the dreaded hairy baby I can't
come in to work today
oh what's the matter my wife gave birth
to a hairy baby yeah dude it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
I thought it was a I thought it was a
little gorilla Oh turns out she had
[ __ ] hair all over she just got waxed
all right dear Reds red Sonia I don't
know what that means I hope I said Sonia
deso nja should I look that one up
I mean if it's an insult I got to see
what it is I want to share on the left
other than the fact I can't pronounce it
or know what it is red Sonia what is red
Sonia red Sonia 1985 is a vengeful woman
sets out to achieve a magic orb with an
ER I got to see images of this Jesus
Christ she's [ __ ] smoking hot
I don't know what that means but anyways
dear red Sonia heard the email from the
guy with the hairy Brazilian gross is
another one this is another one there's
a lot of hairy ladies I have a
suggestion for the other guys in surreal
situation have bill burr address it for
you listen to the podcast over the
speakers when your girl is home that way
you'll plant a seed in her brain and
hopefully get her
shave with and wax without even
addressing it yourself also play that
[ __ ] part of the podcast when they're
around you know what women are way more
complex than that that's a [ __ ]
decent idea and because what's going to
happen shoot if she's self-conscious
about that if the light goes off she's
going to be like that's first [ __ ] I got
stupid that guy shouldn't up a bottle
bubble blah and then about a half hour
that [ __ ] she'll finally come around
to saying like do you think there's like
I know I'm a little more hairier than
most girls does it bother you it's still
going to come back to you if women were
that [ __ ] easy to deal with
emotionally we wouldn't die eight years
before them there's no [ __ ] way it
would be that easy like they're just
going to listen to the podcast and it's
going to click and be like oh wow maybe
I should wax I'm going to do that and
not have a [ __ ] four-hour UN meeting
with my [ __ ] boyfriend anyway she
said I've done the same thing in the
past with great success
okay maybe I'm wrong wait a minute wait
hit the replay going over to the replay
booth I happened to listen to an episode
he said I happened in quotes to listen
to an episode about lip hair when we
were driving three days later
mustache was gone try it it just might
work
holy [ __ ] alright well [ __ ] it give it a
shot I stand corrected I apologize sir I
apologize Jesus Christ I just pictured
the referee coming back saying no goal
but he actually came back said the goal
was allowed you lost sight of the puck
and the mustache still left it's
incredible all right all the best from
Sweden okay what am i up to here 50
[ __ ] minutes all right
okay career crossroads hey Billy
[ __ ] I like that guy he didn't try
to be creative he just went right for it
I am a 17-year old high school senior
going to into college studying pre-law
and ever since I was young I wanted to
go into the military my father owns a
met
compliance company has promised me a job
after college should I get a law degree
however he was redone Jesus Christ you
know I just realized I got to do
something hang on I gotta start this
[ __ ] I get hit pause and I got to
start this [ __ ] question over again I
gotta unlock the door here hang on
alright I'm back I didn't need to unlock
the door she had a key so some reason I
think she had a keys and she the lovely
Lea is going to come on hopefully in a
minute and dress the [ __ ] the growing
controversy of the hairy girlfriend how
do you tell her alright so here we go
hey Billy hey Billy [ __ ] I am a
17-year old high school senior going
into college studying pre-law and ever
since I was young I wanted to go into
the military my father owns a medical
compliance company has promised me a job
after college should I get a law degree
why would you get a law degree then
working in a medical compliance company
Oh medical I thought I was thinking like
they supplied like appliances I keep
selling like [ __ ] dental drills and
[ __ ]
however he has recently talked about
selling the company and retiring as he
is nearing 70 and not getting any
younger my question is this after I
finished college should I enlist in the
military something that I've wanted as
long as I can remember or should I stick
with the safer option
never choose safe taking over my
father's business
slash securing a safe lifelong career
now dude that that is a recipe for what
if [ __ ] that dude you're young you don't
have any kids just risk risk risk risk
risk I'm not saying [ __ ] jump off a
bridge here I'm just saying yeah go big
you go big when you're young you know
she'd never go out with me [ __ ] ask
her out gives a [ __ ] right oh my god I
can't try to do that that's a one in a
zillion chance just go [ __ ] do it
listen to how I read out loud
how [ __ ] horrific I am and I've been
tremendously successful telling [ __ ]
jokes now if I can do it believe me
anybody can do it and you can too if
that's what you want to do you should
definitely do it anyways you said I'm
worried
during my absence in the military
there's a strong possibility my father
will say screw it and sell the business
I'm at a loss because on one hand I
don't want to sit at a desk ten years
from now thinking about what could have
been a great experience in the military
but on the other hand I don't want to
lose a job and my thought that my
father's and be stuck at a soul-sucking
law firm for 30 years in a tiny cubicle
working to make someone else's dream
come true I'm really at a crossroads
here and I don't want to make the wrong
choice that could potentially [ __ ] me
over big time what would you do if you
are my shoes thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself I would go into the military
I'd finish your law degree that's what
you want to do I would go into the
military join the branch that you wanted
to I would [ __ ] crush it in the
military and then when I come out I
would be such you know I would attack
being a lawyer at the same the same
attitude why do you feel like you're
going to be stuck in a tiny tiny cubicle
why wouldn't you move up become partner
you need to dream bigger dreams dude
this whole thing of like you know the
only way you're going to be successful
in the business world is if you take a
job for your dad [ __ ] that dude if you
go the other route you become a
self-made man and when you become a
self-made man you get a belief and a
confidence in yourself and you don't
worry like you're 17 you're already
you're already worrying [ __ ] that you
got your whole life ahead of you I would
go out and do everything that you want
to do and then one day all 20 years goes
by and all of a sudden you're like holy
[ __ ] I work for myself I'm making great
money I can go to the movies whenever I
want to I can take a vacation you know I
could talk [ __ ] on a podcast like it
just completely opens the world opens up
for you but you know if you go the safe
route you know there's that there's that
there's that [ __ ] knowing that
haunting voice in the back ahead what if
I did this what if I did that
he starts sleeping at night huh all
right [ __ ] thrashing and [ __ ] I think
you're going to do great in the military
and I think you'd do great as a lawyer
and that's what you should be thinking
yeah that's it and
I meet some [ __ ] beautiful woman and
should get married or whatever whatever
the [ __ ] is you want to do just think
positive thoughts and surround yourself
with people that feel that way and if
you have a friend that sees you start to
do well and you feel them starting to
become negative address it and if they
don't [ __ ] clean up their [ __ ] you
cut them out of your life because those
people will bring you down stay here at
the townie bar with the old football
jacket on [ __ ] that all right good luck
to you sir
all right dating an older lady and old
abroad hey Billy Boy [ __ ] not been in a
serious relationship with an older woman
she is fantastic cooks for me rubs my
feet gives me sponge baths and just an
absolute gem she has a great job makes a
boatload of cash I guess SS Karol es CA
ro le I don't want to say that word and
I also do very well for myself money is
not an issue I deeply care for her and
love her I'm 30 and she is 45 but she
looks better than most girls my age when
we first met I thought she was 32 so
that's what initially attracted me to
her she's [ __ ] slammin hot and a
great person and has a great personality
we can joke around and I could say
disturbing things to her and she just
laughs real class act type abroad she
was an eighteen year old daughter she
has an 18 year old daughter but as far
as I'm concerned I don't really give a
flying [ __ ] my family had some opinions
and we're like she's too old blah blah
blah [ __ ] them they have miserable
relationships she makes me a better
person I feel good your thoughts your
thoughts Billy little sack Jesus Christ
is [ __ ] everybody they give me the
old [ __ ] one-two there well dude you
sound like you're happy that's what the
[ __ ] you want the what there's nothing
wrong with it that's what you want
there's nothing [ __ ] wrong with it
she makes you happy yeah absolutely
why would you leave you know I don't
know if you want to have kids that might
that would be a [ __ ] issue you know
at that point you freeze our [ __ ]
eggs and you jerk off into something I
don't know it works I don't pretend to
be a doctor I'll [ __ ] you know what I
didn't read the other
the other advertisements all right let
me just knock out these last really
quickly let's see how fast I can read
these all right this is going to be a
[ __ ] train wreck simple faith I'm
like a read assess simple safe everybody
thousands of people seeking home
security get ripped off every day and
the home security industry wants you to
believe it's your only option
they've got hordes of salesmen out there
trying to scare you into signing one of
their long term contracts you get stuck
writing huge checks month after month
with no way out it's robbery by contract
and it can cost you thousands but
there's a better way to protect your
home with temple faiths home security
simple faith has no contracts none
you'll get award-winning 24/7 protection
named best in the industry security
professionals watching ready to
instantly send the people the police and
it's just $14.99 a month $14.99 that's
less than half of what most companies
charge protect your home this smart way
visits simple faith bird calm
there's no slash there's nothing I'm
going to guess there's a slash that
simple save slash bird calm but the same
simple safe bird calm try one or the
other for an exclusive 10% offer and get
a free key chain remote worth $25 only
when you go to simple flight bird calm
that simple faith bird calm MVM tea
watches everybody when you're in your
early 20s and 30s money can be tight if
you're not careful dressing well can
quickly drain your bank account like
spending four to five hundred bucks on a
department store watch there's some
brands out there that are charging
insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it well if you want to look
great when you go out but still have
enough money to buy him or her a drink
check out movement watches calm I've
seen them before and these watches are
sharp originally found by two founded by
two broke college kids women watches cut
out the middleman and they're big brand
retail markups and yet cut out the
middleman and they're big brand retail
markups in order to give you a stylish
watch for an affordable price movement
watches just start at $95 a watch what
department store
baldie for a fraction of the price
there's sleek and minimalistic a modern
twist on a classic style movement has
grown occasionally organically sorry
purely by supporters like you to join
their more than 1 million social media
media followers and get a movement
watched today go to mV mt watches calm /
/ and they'll save you 15% off your
entire purchase MV mt watches calm / /
and lastly but not leastly Dollar Shave
Club - peoples dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing razors right to your
door for a third of the price of what
the greedy raising raising raising
raising corporations judged that means
when you join Dollar Shave Club you can
afford to shave with the fresh blade
anytime you want which feels fantastic
you get a first-class shave when you use
the executive blade and that's without
even hurting your wallet and when you
use the executive blade with the dr.
cabbies easy shake but dr. carver shea
butter the blade gently the blade just
gently glides for the smoothest shave
ever shave butter isn't your average
shave cream its unique conditioning
formula with high-quality natural
ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth now it's a
great time to join Dollar Shave Club new
members who buy a tube of shaved butter
get a month on the of the executive
razor for free take advantage of this
special offer today it's available by
going to dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / and lastly if
you want to donate to this podcast
without it costing you a [ __ ] dime
anytime you're going to buy something on
amazon if you go to my podcast page you
click on the little amazon link there it
takes you right to Amazon doesn't cost
you any extra money and I get credit for
driving traffic there if you want to if
you don't that's [ __ ] cool to a niet
do you want to read this thing with me
okay alright well that's the end of the
podcast but she's going to come here in
the end and we're going to uh I don't
little bonus like 5 minute thing here
this could
goes south very easily but we'll see
what happens hang on let me hit pause
alright the lovely knee everybody hi how
are you I'm crazy okay let's get right
down to it okay all right
this guy he's dating this woman she
thinks she's beautiful but she's hairy
this thing again
well yeah but I never you never talk to
about we never got a female's advice on
this I thought we did you talked about
it yeah remember I said like either like
he sort of gets something waxed and they
go together and it's funny or he just
like gets over it you said that on the
podcast or did we talk about that on our
own not on the podcast you got all mad
at me because I was like if she's not
what do you have against talking into
the mic I don't know you just sit there
going like I said I know people tweeted
me the last time was like I can't hear
you so I told me yeah just of the mic
just having follow your mouth okay but
because the thing is I feel like if a
microphone is anywhere near me it's
going to microphone my voice so I
amplified yeah
well though I don't need it's very rare
that someone makes me look like a smart
one microphone my voice oh um well what
you have to know is what eyes about it
but microphones each one of them aha
they have these ones that are designed
to pick up 360 there's ones that are
like these ones are like directly on
okay so if it's directly on that the
reason for that is if there's other
background noise you don't want to pick
that up there's other microphones design
where you want to hear the whole room
these are directly on so you got to
speak into it but this is not what we're
talking about okay so alright so I
thought oh my goodness and she's got
like a like hair on her lower back yeah
like right with a [ __ ] stamp would be
that she was like she could have a [ __ ]
stamp and he wouldn't know right because
it's the whole thicket of hair under
that yeah I thought we talked about this
I thought you stopped saying that okay I
understand that you think that we talked
about it neither one of us can remember
if we did it on the podcast or not this
is just bonus time anyways all right
to refresh our listeners well my date a
woman she's got a [ __ ] afro right
above her butt crack what do you say
something wrong with an afro um on ya
head mm-hmm
boo boo boo I think you have to answer
the goddamn question
it's a tough one how long has he been
dating this person it can he be like so
what's with your little furry back over
here you're like my little chia pet in a
cute way what can you say in a cute way
how do you say that in a cute way I
don't know myself
oh you're my little chia pet back here
yeah well you know what maybe he could
just sort of like this is gonna sound
really [ __ ] weird but maybe this is
like stroke it or whatever the thing is
she'll probably like oh god no don't
touch that I know there's like a hair
back there it's so like weird I hate it
you can go why don't you get it waxed
and she might be like I don't know like
I'm embarrassed I'll go with you I'll
lack something with you how about that
I'll whack something you whack something
I have an idea that's a good idea I have
an idea - what about when you know she's
wearing like a sexy shirt so it doesn't
quite reach down to her pants when she
goes to get up off probably doesn't wear
shirts like that when she goes to get up
off the couch you just reach up and grab
her a little back and go get back down
here
that's lie on her stomach at the beach
and he starts braiding it for her I know
it's bad it's bad isn't as your
questionable sister shouldn't well this
one guy was saying he was dating this
when she had like even hairy feet she
like hairy toes [ __ ] happens man I know
but what the [ __ ] me it you got to
handle that I mean ideally yes you would
handle that in a perfect world in a
perfect world but you know I had
girlfriends for years who had a little
adjust like the little shade of a
mustache and they just never it just
never really occurred to them to wax it
into like recently I remember I had a
friend I saw I hadn't seen in a while
and she was like do you notice anything
different and she kept turning her face
in a certain way and I was like yeah you
get your upper lip wax you don't look
like you Reynolds any more yeah she's
like I said I did
it she's like I don't know I was always
just intimidated to go into the place
and she doesn't but I'm so glad I did so
I think that what it is yeah people are
self-conscious and you think you'll go
in there and you'll get judgment by the
waxing person but the waxing person has
waxed you know
Chewbacca down there so they don't care
that's their job so it could be that
she's just like a little embarrassed to
go to a place and have it taken off
because who wants to say oh I have to go
get my back waxed today well you don't
have to say that you just walk down yeah
and go hey can you wax my back you don't
even have to whisper it I know you don't
so oh no but if you go there to other
people see you getting your back wax no
no no you're in a private room Oh
whenever you get any kind of waxing
service it's not oh oh do and they're
like Steve Carell oh yeah exactly
yeah so you are in a private thing so
you just have to do it in a cute you
know just one [ __ ] did why he goes I
suggest you don't tell the woman that
she's hairy he told the woman he broke
up with her and said the reason why he
was doing it was because she was so
hairy is that's not the way to do is is
that the meanest thing you've ever
[ __ ] meanest thing ever
yes that's something that are you that
shallow because that's something that's
easily fixable are you that [ __ ]
shallow that you break up with someone
as your hairy back like what a [ __ ]
apples back feet nose lot coming out of
the nose and then the arms that's just
that's unnecessary to say that after the
fact if you love somebody not and
there's even if you don't even if you
don't love somebody you don't do that to
somebody yeah now that's not that's not
okay
but then so then she [ __ ] he came she
started throwing plates and he [ __ ]
left and he came back she dumped bleach
on his clothes and stapled some condoms
to the [ __ ] wall the usual
destruction of property that for some
reason to use validated do you have I've
never actually noticed do you have back
hair yet looking back hair yet like
correct oh right that something has men
get older I have actually never knocked
on no I don't have back here let me same
well Jesus Christ me we [ __ ] sleep
next to me every goddamn day I just
never thought to look for that no I
don't have back here you know what there
is a very
little area in the lower back [ __ ]
stamp area not a lot you can barely see
it as your hair so fair but like no no
you have a very small like that I got
nothing back there there's nothing back
there I mean there's more on your chest
and on those your lower yeah very small
amount but the thing is I feel like in
10 years that [ __ ] could get a little
bit in 10 years I'm going to be close to
60 I mean I still have you accent what
in ten years we might white [ __ ] back
hair against my white back because it
bothers you when I wear a [ __ ] half
shirt I mean what it was what are we
doing at that point it's a better way
look at my lower back let's just you
listen no you don't know you don't know
okay you don't
well I'm yeah I try to very familiar
with your lower back you don't know yeah
you don't you're not a hairy person so
but if I was hairy back there would you
say something to me no I just want to
broke up with you what so you would have
broken up over it because I want to
taking the time to fall in love with you
if you're walking around looking like
[ __ ] Burt Reynolds in Playgirl okay
oh I see a Photoshop yeoman oh my god
Melda I mean wait shut up to have the mm
Photoshop on Twitter oh my god dude that
one with me standing in front of the
fountain I [ __ ] dude we were in the
writers room when I saw that and I
[ __ ] laughed so hard yeah like one of
the other eyes was going like what what
and I showed it to him and everyone was
going like oh my god that's so mean I
got a [ __ ] hilarious and I love the
picture of you that they found you was
weather yeah it was like when you were
going out to some event so you look that
was us at the heat premiere yeah that's
what that picture was I was trying to be
like [ __ ] you know modest about it
and want to sit there and say you were
at a movie premiere so you had some big
event you always did I just be standing
there you always have to [ __ ] drop
the Hollywood [ __ ] don't you Lee is
trying to personally contact the
premiere for
now cinematic film the heat where my
husband had two lines you had more than
two if you sneezed in that movie you
missed me but now everybody follow the
mmm Photoshop on Twitter yeah whoever
that is man a woman is [ __ ] hilarious
wait wait wait actually we have a better
one for the mmm Photoshop all right so
wait where's my phone
because I wrote it down remember you
said the name of the movie and it was
once again how you have just sort of
clues from the movie and I don't
remember the titles all right so I'm
going to find it because it was
definitely one your classic ones and
we're not going to say what the movie is
we're just going to have the mm
Photoshop wait and receiving planet mock
it up put it on Twitter and then
everyone will be able to guess hopefully
all right so you called this movie I'm
going to kill you on Wall Street there
[ __ ] oh I'm gonna kill you already there
[ __ ] oh that's a movie set
that was it move now that's a movie so
people are going to try to guess what it
is mmm Photoshop is gonna know it's
funny date later movie poster days later
you reading that it now sounds like
somebody else says it said it and it's a
terrible clue that's not even close it's
sort of close don't figure it out all
right well it's 12 minutes past the hour
here it's time to wrap this up because
up in this nasty house on our WBUR our
Morning Becomes eclectic I love you
listen to that you think it makes you
smarter all right that's it no it's so
pretentious to be smart out good KCRW to
get a variety of particle size saying
liberal viewpoint all right you done
that was over Jenna why go somewhere
need my own no you know what it is I
just I don't like [ __ ] that's a hundred
percent liberal or 100 percent
conservative all right that's fine I
like in the milk because both of them
caused me to yell at them well and we go
at everything it doesn't matter what it
is not true because nothing is exactly
your viewpoint
I don't yell at you what I don't yell at
the dog that's also not sure I don't
yell at other drivers
I'm courteous I'm polite I don't yell at
inanimate objects like my computer I
don't have any of those Thanks sure
well then all right then to me I want to
know you're like a redheaded Gandhi yeah
I definitely look like Ben Kingsley more
than I look like [ __ ] Donnie Danny
Bonaduce all right that's the that's the
podcast here for the for this Monday
anybody do Danny Bonaduce
got a situation with danny bonadu--
Danny what do we got to take some care
the [ __ ] all right that's it I'll
talk to you fuckos on Thursday don't
[ __ ] yourselves